don't be afraid I don't know if it's
just me but I find a lot when I have
commitments I've made to other people
that just before I'm supposed to go in
and meet with them or call them or
whatever it is for some reason I kind of
secretly hope they're gonna cancel on me
I don't know why that is you know I just
got off a google+ hangout with a
mompreneur she's got a new clothing line
coming out and we're having a few
technical issues at the start and I was
kind of secretly hoping that we would
postpone it to another time and it have
been a great chat and it always is you
know and and I now I feel great you know
it took me you know 25 30 minutes of my
time and she is so appreciative and her
her business is gonna change because of
it and it makes me feel great you know
this is what I love doing I love helping
entrepreneurs I love helping them make
changes and yet I was kind of secretly
hoping that the call wouldn't happen for
whatever reason I don't know why I do
this I don't know if you guys do it too
what helps me is is I you know first of
all about committing other people you
have to you have to go through with it
because you've committed to them so
unless they cancel you know you don't
want to be the one canceling but then I
also have to kind of remind myself that
hey you like this stuff you're gonna
feel great once it starts so hopefully
you learn something from that you know I
guess this happens to all of us are
maybe I'm unique for whatever case but
you know don't be afraid don't be afraid
remember this is what you're good at
remember this is what you love doing and
you're gonna feel great once you're in
it and afterwards and I keep pushing
forward believe you guys like this video
a thumbs up below leave a comment ask a
question of make a video response and
click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon